[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très connu mais nelson mes frères sur la
tête de 20 jeux tilt a tenu en effet le
prof d'histoire mais arthur ou baba où
cyril hanouna
si tu dit arthur je te défoncer la
gueule à la fin je vais dire arthur
tient mot car sur le monde la bête vous
avez raison mais les deux ils sont aussi
cons la clôture et vous venez nous voir
d'abord avant tout pour le mondial de la
veste un bien sûr voilà du cachemire au
delà du bureau nice on a bien sûr de
l'alcool injustice il faut regarder
alors ici des surpiqûres les avaient pas
sur la saison 2013 sur la saison 2014
elles sont magnifiques
valérie bénaïm ou enora malagré les deux
en même temps c'est bien le porter
pourrait faire un parti alors
[Applaudissements]
êtes vous oui ou non nelson monfort
ouais ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
télévision philippe ou pas toujours vers
la semaine prochaine je pars avec nelson
aux championnats du monde attendait bien
avec nelson mais ça va on s'entend bien
on vient nous voir la semaine prochaine
je crois voulez-vous dire un petit truc
ben nelson ne raconte pas trop de
conneries parce que on doit faire de
l'audimat quand même vous avez pas un
truc sur nelson monfort qu'on sait pas
qu'on pourra lui sorti la semaine
prochaine
vous savez pas mais vous savez tout sur
nelson n'y a pas une petite anecdote je
sais pas il connaît bien des blagues de
cul demandez lui qui le raconte une
femme et moi de la pluie et non pas du
beau temps beau temps me dégoûte me fait
grincer des dents le bel azur me met en
rage eux car les grands bonheurs qui me
fuit donner sur terre je le dois au
mauvais temps jol d'oise et jupiter
il me tomba d'un ciel d'orage il connaît
le rotin philippaerts à fond de vous
vous avez un petit truc vous êtes hyper
sympathique mais il ya tout juste un
petit truc c'est que vous êtes proche de
vous sous tout le monde le dit à chaque
fois
passez-moi 50 euros j'étais pas là je te
les passes mais tu m'invites au resto ou
alors ils sont ils y passent mais tu
m'invites voilà [ __ ] c'est mon
parquet d'aix et broc maire si c'est bon
match à cadeaux
merci nous on aime être ici donc voilà
ça faisait mouche l'avion qui tombera
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]